there are now 21 people officially vying
for the Democratic presidential
nomination the latest entry Colorado
Senator Michael Bennet
president Trump just told Fox News
Bennet has no chance to win
correspondent Peter Doocy tells us what
Bennet is up against and what he is
already defeated Michael Bennett knows
all about uphill battles he represents
the Rockies and now the senator who just
beat prostate cancer is trying to be
twenty other Democrats I called my mom
and I said to her somebody has to be
twenty-two and that's why I'm running
and it turns out I'm not I'm twenty-one
so I've already made a little bit of
progress and it's race to qualify for
next month's debate begins today cory
booker's began in february but he
started today almost 2,000 donors short
of the 65,000 needed to guarantee a spot
that's something that won't be a problem
for Jill Biden who is raising eyebrows
arguing China isn't the problem they're
not bad folks folks but guess what
competition for us that wasn't a gap
because Biden has been saying it for
years China we used to expression a
little steel town I moved to from
Scranton Pennsylvania called Clayman
these guys aren't an economic patch on
our genes they're not close Bernie
Sanders disagrees tweeting quote it's
wrong to pretend that China isn't one of
our major economic competitors many
other contenders are just as cautious we
are getting our clocks cleaned by China
China is getting stronger militarily and
economically china is attacking us
through the internet every single day
Democrats are also coming together to
call for attorney general bill Barr to
resign including Kamala Harris Elizabeth
Warren Beto O'Rourke and Jill Biden a
lots changed since 1991 I think you're
personally I can work with the RNC is
attacking Biden's foreign policy chops
today for something that happened eight
years ago this week the SEAL Team six
raid that killed bin Laden pointing out
that in a 2012 speech Biden recalled
advising Obama not to go that night like
Peter Doocy here in Washington Peter
thanks we're happy to announce another
Fox News townhall featuring a Democratic
presidential candidate New York
senator Kirsten Gillibrand will join
Chris Wallace in Iowa Sunday June 2nd at
7:00 p.m. Eastern
next Wednesday Bret Baier and martha
maccallum will host Minnesota senator
Amy Klobuchar from Milwaukee at 6:30
p.m. Eastern and on Sunday May 19th at 7
p.m. Eastern South Bend mayor Pete Budaj
will be our guest with Chris Wallace
from Claremont New Hampshire